here a few stories we think you'll be  talking about today more than 2 million  pounds of chicken from Simmons prepared  foods are being recalled over possible  metal contamination the recall includes  fresh and frozen chicken products  including pulled chickens wings and  breast meat they were shipped to  institutions in eight states there have  been no reports of anyone getting sick  Simmons says they are working closely  with regulators to expedite the recall  anyone who has the contaminated meat is  being urged to throw it out immediately  that's why you should just go to Popeyes  and get back in this building now back  oh yes I've had people who've never had  it before they had it this week they say  amazing amazing proceeding has been a  paid endorsement  [Laughter]